hoy lose ahora que ya tenemos una cuenta
en khan academy como maestros y hemos
creado nuestra primera clase vamos a
aprender a configurar la y agregar a los
estudiantes estamos en nuestra página
principal como maestros dentro de
nuestra cuenta de khan academy así que
vamos a entrar a la clase que creamos
matemática quinto a del curso del mundo
las matemáticas le hacemos clic aquí
y vamos a la pestaña donde dice primero
configuración para aprender a configurar
nuestra cuenta aquí en esta pestaña
podemos cambiar el nombre de la clase
por ejemplo si tuviéramos en este caso
en matemática una clase de matemática de
quinto a turno mañana y otro turno tarde
le puedo agregar aquí turno a m para la
mañana le doy clic a guardar
inmediatamente se cambien la parte
superior como se puede ver no también
podría cambiar el curso haciéndole clic
a esta a esta pestaña donde dice cambiar
curso y también podría descargar los
datos de los estudiantes en formato
excel y luego clic en esta parte
ahora quiero agregar estudiantes
entonces vamos a la parte donde dice la
pestaña donde dice lista
dando click aquí
y me sale la opción de agregar nuevos
estudiantes
como vimos cuando creamos la clase nos
salen tres opciones vamos a ir primero
por la segunda que es la de compartir el
link con nuestros estudiantes
le ponemos listo
este es el código de la clase de
compartir con los estudiantes y que está
aquí en la esquina superior derecha
cada clase tiene un código diferente se
sugiere a veces que los maestros puedan
escribir esto o ponerlo en la pizarra o
pedirle alguno de los alumnos que lo
haga cartel y pegarlo porque ese es el
código que siempre acompañará a esa
clase entonces en este caso no lo voy a
copiar
y ahora voy a pasar a rol de estudiante
para que ustedes le pueden explicar a
los estudiantes cómo tienen que hacer
eso
ustedes mismos también lo pueden hacer
como maestros porque también tienen
activos se acuerdan el rol de
estudiantes hacemos clic en nuestro
nombre la esquina superior derecha es el
menú y vamos donde dice página de inicio
del aprendizaje
esta página es la página de los
estudiantes
entonces lo primero que nos va a
preguntar y que le va a preguntar a su
estudiante cuando se cree en su cuenta
como estudiantes es en qué grado están
entonces vamos a poner por ejemplo que
aquí estamos en haber segundo secundaria
continuaron
y en qué cursos podemos ayudarte no
imaginemos que este estudiante elige al
médico y biología por ejemplo puede
elegir todos los cursos que quiere el
estudiante esto sirve para que la
plataforma le sugiera algunos temas
entonces pone continúa con estos dos
cursos y lo va a guardar entonces así es
como nuestros estudiantes van a ver su
página a está bien ya la plataforma
misma me sugiere temas con los que puedo
empezar a aprender pero ahora lo que
queremos es que no es estudiante según a
nuestra clase como maestros entonces lo
que tengo que pedir al estudiante es que
una vez que él se cree su cuenta con un
email y con una contraseña y le aparezca
esta pantalla vaya en la pestaña donde
dice tutores aquí en esta barrita las
explica tutores bueno una vez que va a
la página donde dice tutores le aparece
esta página y aquí lo invita a unirse a
una clase entonces en la barra donde
aparece escribir el código voy a poner
el código de la clase que yo creé en
este caso entonces sus estudiantes
tendrían que poner el código de sus
clases
este es el código de la clase que yo
creé y simplemente le tienen que dar
click a únete a la clase
entonces aquí como ven quiere decir que
el tutor de ese estudiante es en este
caso el profesor contacto perú que es el
que yo misma he creado y esto es lo que
sus estudiantes tienen que hacer y
ustedes mismos también pueden hacerlo si
quisieran unirse a su clase como
estudiantes para ver cómo los
estudiantes están viendo las tareas
entonces ahora como profesor lo que
tengo que hacer es volver a mi página
principal del profesor
le hago clic aquí arriba donde dice khan
academy
y como ven aquí donde dice contacto perú
en la esquina superior derecha me sale
una notificación y voy aquí donde dice
notificaciones y me dice en tu primer
estudiante acepto tu invitación
si ven aquí mismo donde parece mi clase
matemática quinto a turno a m me parece
que ya tengo un estudiante
y el hecho de que ya tenga un estudiante
o más me habilita a que ella pueda
activar las tareas que había había
elegido para mi clase yo aquí me dice
tienes un nuevo estudiante en esta clase
de bushehr actualizar las tareas
existentes pues le pongo actualizado
aquí les voy a pedir que siempre vayan
donde dice lista la barra y certifiquen
que estén todos los estudiantes de su
clase esto es muy importante porque si
ustedes van dejando tareas y algún
estudiante no se ha unido correctamente
a la clase no va a aparecer aquí y no
ustedes no van a poder ver su progreso
ni ellos van a poder hacer sus tareas
ahora lo que quiero hacer es activar las
tareas que ya había elegido entonces voy
a la pestaña de tareas
a donde sea guardadas
y simplemente lo que tengo que hacer es
hacerle clic aquí donde dice asignar e
inmediatamente se van asignando las
tareas a mi clase
porque ya tengo al menos un estudiante
si quisiera buscar nuevas tareas ya
saben que puedo ir a la pestaña de
contenido
y buscar nuevas cosas por ejemplo en
este caso quiero ver temas de
sumas y restas de fracciones con
denominadores comunes
luego utilice esta parte
en la casilla de la derecha luego
asignar ahí lo que son siete tareas
de esta la clase todos los estudiantes
pongo la fecha récord en la fecha la
última fecha es la fecha límite en la
que los estantes pueden hacer la tarea
la hora y le doy clic a asignado y con
eso mis estudiantes van a recibir una
notificación que su profesor les ha
dejado un nueva tarea
si ustedes quieren verlo como
estudiantes
van clic hacen clic a su nombre en la
esquina superior derecha
van a la página de inicio el aprendizaje
y yo como estoy dentro de mi clase
también como un estudiante puedo hacer
clic aquí donde dice tareas
y me aparecen todas las tareas que me ha
dejado mi profesor en este caso soy yo
misma si ustedes ven en las tareas
destaca el nombre de tarea la clase a la
que pertenece la tarea y la fecha y hora
límite como ven acá tengo tres tareas
para mañana y otras que son para
diciembre 15
todas las tareas que tengan una estrella
en el lado izquierdo son ejercicios los
que tengan un triángulo son vídeos
el estudiante quiere empezar la idea es
que simplemente le dé clic aquí en la
casilla derecha donde dice empezar e
inmediatamente va a poder comenzar a
hacer los ejercicios
en este caso por ejemplo voy a poner una
respuesta cualquiera para que ustedes
puedan ver como un estudiante va
respondiendo
si fuera incorrecto le va a parecer una
llamada como ésta que dice vuelve a
intentarlo y te da una retroalimentación
inmediata para que el estudiante pueda
obtener la respuesta correcta por
ejemplo si la utiliza en obtener ayuda
si bien aparece una explicación de cómo
podría haber llegado la respuesta
correcta y me sugiere vídeos que me van
a explicar este tema
ahora voy a volver
de nuevo a la página principal como
maestro haciendo clic arriba en khan
academy
y como acaben en la clase que cree
ya tengo un estudiante ya le dejé tareas
y están listos para comenzar otra forma
de agregar estudiantes a nuestras clases
de stand academy es entrando a nuestra
clase vamos a la pestaña donde dice
lista
en la parte superior agregar nuevos
estudiantes
y usamos la tercera opción que crea las
cuentas para tus alumnos y es que el
maestro ahí tiene qué
escribir cada uno de los nombres
estudiantes y se va a generar un nombre
de usuario y una contraseña entonces
vamos a hacer un ejemplo para que lo
puedan ver imaginemos que yo tengo un
estudiante que se llama maría
pérez
aquí la plataforma inmediatamente genera
un usuario que se llama maría pérez 9 39
le doy clic enter en su teclado
y me deja escribir el siguiente nombre
más que otro se llama josé
días
le hago clic enter y así sucesivamente
con todos los estudiantes de mi clase
esto sí bien es más trabajoso a veces
funciona cuando los estudiantes no
tienen correo electrónico y no se pueden
crear sus cuentas ellos solos nosotros
desde khan academy sugerimos que los
estudiantes idealmente tengan sus
cuentas personales con sus mails porque
la plataforma además les va a ir
mandando correos avisando en sus tareas
y además invitándolos a seguir
aprendiendo
pero si no lo tuvieran esta es una forma
la clima esto puede crear las cuentas
para los alumnos le hace clic aquí donde
dice siguiente en la parte inferior
y como ven en la plataforma genera
contraseñas pero el maestro las puede
cambiar
por una única vez entonces acá por
ejemplo imaginemos que yo le voy a poner
una contraseña más fácil como
matemáticas
2000 por ejemplo y voy a ponerle la
misma a todos mis estudiantes para que
no se olviden y siempre entren a
simplemente poner su nombre de usuario y
sus contraseñas que todos las tienen
compartidas en ese momento le hago clic
a crear cuentas en la parte inferior
y aquí la plataforma me dice que puedo
descargar los nombres los usuarios y las
contraseñas de mis alumnos por única vez
por motivos de privacidad le pongo
descargar
si lo ven en la parte inferior se abre
un documento vamos a abrirlo y aquí
estarán todos los nombres los
estudiantes
el nombre del usuario lo ven con la
contraseña
esta es otra forma de agregar a mis
estudiantes a la clase
y aquí como profesor me va a ser que
tengo dos alumnos nuevos
le doy clic actualizar y me aparecen no
uno el primero con el primer estudiante
que agregue lo hice a través del código
de la clase lo que me agregue a mí misma
como maestra y a la vez como estudiante
y dos cuentas que yo he creado con sus
contraseñas